My name is Gary Stevenson i grew up around here
in East London from quite a poor family in quite
a poor area but in 2008 when i was 21 i got a
job working for Citibank in canary wharf not far
from here as an interest rate trader my job was to
bet whether interest rates would go up or go down
now interest rates go up when the economy isstrong
and they come down when the economy is weak
so basically my job is to bet on the strength of
the global economy now when i started working in
2008 there was a global financial crisis and all
the rates in the whole world came down to zero
so very quickly my job was to bet on when will
the rates recover which is basically a bet on when
will the global economy recover now the history of
this is super interesting in 2008 governments and
central banks all over the world printed a huge
amount of money and pushed it into the economy
that meant that stock prices bounced super quickly
and economists and traders predicted that the
economy would recover super quickly too so in
2008 they predicted a v-shaped recovery for 2009.
now in 2009 that didn't happen that
prediction got pushed back to 2010.
in 2010 it got pushed back to 2011. in 2011 it
got pushed back to 2012. in 2012 it was 2013 and
back last year in 2020 they were still predictinga
recovery for later that year and yet here we are in
2021 with global interest rates just like
the global economy still at emergency lows
now before i started working in the city i studied
economics and i became fascinated in understanding
why are our predictions always wrong? why do
we always predict the economy is going to
recover when it doesn't recover? when is the
economy going to recover? will it ever recover?
and underlying those questions is
one big question why aren't people
spending more money? now in 2008 when that huge
wave of new money got pushed into the economy
economists thought people are going to
spend this money and that's going to cause
a massive economic boom when that didn't
happen economists didn't understand why
but for me having grown up around here in a place
like this i felt that i could understand why now
if you print a huge amount of money it's important
where that money goes people like my family people
like the people i grew up with people like
the people around here who would have spent
that money if they got it weren't getting it
instead the money was going to people like
the people i was working with in the city or even
the super rich people whose money we were moving
now the problem is when money goes to the rich and
the super rich they don't spend it that means it
doesn't boost the economy instead they use it to
buy stocks and houses that pushes stock prices and
house prices up when that happens it doesn't help
ordinary people it makes it harder for ordinary
people to save and it makes it harder for ordinary
people to buy houses that means if we print money
but it only goes to the rich it doesn't make the
economy better in fact it makes the economy worse
now i could see that if we didn't fix inequality
the global economy was not going to recover
since economists and politicians weren't
doinganything about it i could tell that the
economy wasn't going to get better any time soon
i bet that the global economy would stay weak for
years and that made me Citibank's most profitable
trader and that's how i became a millionaire
because i knew the difference between the
economy down here and the economy over there
listen if we don't do anything about wealth
inequality the economy doesn't get better,
housing doesn't become more affordable, wages
don't go up, well paid jobs don't become easy toget
all those things get worse, all those things
get more difficult, the economy for our kids
will be worse than this economy and the
economy for their kids will be worse than that
now i'm not just saying these things i'm betting
on them i've been betting on them for 13 years
i've been right for 13 years and
i've made millions of pounds doing it
but things don't have to turn out that way and
i don't want them to there is an alternative
if we actually start reducing wealth inequality
rather than letting it continue to grow we can
put that cycle into reverse we can make the money
go to ordinary people and make their lives better
that will make ordinary people richer and not
only that but ordinary people are going to spend
the money that's going to make the economy
stronger it's going to make the economy boom
more jobs higher wages more opportunities the
opportunity to actually make money to get rich
for ordinary people the chance to get good quality
housing the chance to have financial security to
raise a family without having to worry just
about paying the mortgage or paying the bills
these are the things that we could have if
we actually start reducing wealth inequality
it's possible to do this at the moment we have
a tax system which is very efficient at taxing
ordinary working people but very inefficient
attacks in the super rich often they end up paying
extremely low rates attacks close to zero percent
but in the past we have had tax systems which make
richer people pay more this was the case in the
50s and 60s here in Britain and the result was a
booming economy with low unemployment good jobs
and affordable housing listen that was 60 or 70
years ago if we were to bring in a progressive tax
system like that now the kind of economic boom we
could have could be enormous and that could be
achieved using a wealth tax the idea behind the
wealth tax is that billionaires and millionaires
should pay higher rates of tax than everybody
else ordinary people will not be taxed more but
that money could be used to improve education
to improve health care or to reduce the rates of
tax currently being paid by you and hard-working
families it's finally been supported by prominent
economists and politicians all around the world
and now it has a real chance of happening listen
i'm a millionaire and attacks on millionaires
and billionaires is going to hit me too but
i can see what's going to happen if we don't
fix a broken economic system it's going to get
worse and worse and it's not going to be pretty
but a different future is possible we can have
affordable housing we can have good quality
jobs but we can only have it if we fix wealth
inequality support the wealth tax i do
housing could be so much more affordable wages
could be so much higher and we could have so
many more options in how we live our lives some
of them put a lot of money into paying economists
and think tanks to tell you that inequality
is important for the economy that is not true